(Music)
I went down
to St. James Infirmary
To see my baby there
She was lying on a long wooden table
So cold, so still, so fair
I went up to see the doctor
"She's very low," he said
I went back to see my baby
Good God
she's lying there dead
I went down to old Joe's bar room
On the corner of the square
They were serving drinks as per usual
And the usual crowd was there
To my left stood Old Joe McKennedy
His eyes were bloodshot red
He turned to the crowd around him
And these are the words he said
"Let her go, let her go, God bless her
Wherever she may be
She can search
this whole wide world all over
But she'll never find another man like me
She can search
this whole wide world all over
And she'll never find
another man
like me
When I die, please God, bury me
In my ten-dollar Stetson hat
Put a twenty-dollar gold piece
on my watch chain
So my friends know I died standing pat
Get six gamblers to carry my coffin
And six choir girls to sing me a song
Stick a jazz band on my hearse wagon
To raise hell as I go along
Now that's the end of my story
Let's have another round of booze
And if anyone should ask you
Just tell them I got
the St. James Infirmary
blues
(Applause)